you want to buy 10 euro thank you yeah
you are Parkinson Arabah vet Aria and we
are here in Istanbul and headed to the
grand bazaar one of the oldest and
largest covered markets in the world and
a while ago I was actually able to sell
my headshots for some money at a porn
convention and since I promised our
amazing crew some dessert today I
figured let's go find out if we can make
some more money how do you say corn in
Turkish mush don't slip listen mister
dating back to the 15th century the
grand bazaar continues to be a shopping
mecca for voyagers from around the globe
inside of the Grand Bazaar there's 3,500
shopper ah
it has also 21 entrance and 66 streets
we can say this is the first mall in the
world how long have you been selling at
the Grand Bazaar 21 years at the morning
I was going to school and the afternoon
I came here when I came here I wanted to
learn English for my English or for my
other languages I didn't go in school I
learned that in language from other
people Wow so working here you learn
yeah English like University if you work
six month here it's almost same you know
for four years if you do international
trade school we say every time if Grand
Bazaar and what we gonna do this is like
our home so you've been selling here for
a little bit yeah I'm here today to try
and sell as well yeah what do you think
you like yes I'm gonna sell these
you think I can sell these here the
grand bazaar today haha I don't think so
it's difficult I think ask me why should
I buy them for boys picture you know you
better just write this one in netherland
or something like that yeah
maybe for both of time is more yeah now
is more stronger what is a good price
don't get it - OH - hi 20 lira 20 lira
40 lira 20 lira 20 lira price 10 lira
brother I mean little lira what are some
tips you have any advice for selling say
this is handmade say 10 euro is like $60
and Turkey if you say damn tandra
you get the lab it's profit Wow so
depending on the currency you you
proposed
the more money you can make yes I'll cuz
there I could at best turkey that's a
trick yeah you have to look them if they
have a good look or something like that
maybe it's kind of like well they have
money they can't really convert in their
head right yeah so 10-year tenure Oh
sounds that's nothing in my country but
you say six to zero so much a mini
turkey you don't have chance to see more
than this I don't
[Music]
is it your first time at the grand
bazaar yeah started trouble you're
saying I'm interrupting another guy sale
to make money so I'm wondering if you
would like to buy one of these photos of
me how much a 10 euro for whatever you
want in your living room and your
bedroom the bathroom headshot for sale
the kitchen the garage in your car 10
euro great prices the patio the den the
backyard anyone interested you buy a
picture of where I'm going guys within
your house strange but think about
whenever you look at this photo you'll
remember the beautiful trip you took to
the Grand Bazaar you put this above your
in you you know near your bed you go to
bed you look up you look at that the he
doesn't matter if you don't like men
it's about the experience you see this
picture in the kitchen that you think
wow the memories of a beautiful day a
beautiful trip together to the Grand
Bazaar 7 euro so you know thank you
well you're very super saying that thank
you very much I hope you have a great
day ok no nevermind thank you ok
Oh bye-bye as it turns out trying to
sell headshots at the grand bazaar is a
lot more difficult than a porn
convention and after hours with no luck
I'm very worried that I will be able to
deliver on that sweet victory dessert
treat I had promised my new friends
[Music]
excuse me man
thank you for speaking a very quick
question I was wondering if you would
like to buy one of my headshots 10 euro
you you are you here to buy one yeah
you'll buy one for 10 euro yeah are you
serious you're so nice well why would
you buy my photo
so she has a hundred euro and I have I
actually have eighty US dollars I'll
throw the Turkish lira - which one do
you want thank you so much
I sold one for 10 euro and Europe so we
have the footage well show you the full
show you the footage Aria big sell Aslam
today was a tale of constant rejection
before eventual triumph and despite the
rocky road I'm glad I got first-hand
experience of the beautiful chaos that
is the Grand Bazaar but most importantly
I'm thrilled that I'm able to keep a
promise I made to my new Turkish friends
so should you ever find yourself a nice
town bull be sure to make that trek
through the Grand Bazaar because in this
bustling hub full of life and history
you never know what you just might find
[Music]
makann beautiful handmade products
beautiful handmade headshots hey
unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part
subscribe here that was my part